hey guys so it's probably been about a
full 24 hours since i've got my apple
watch and here are my first impressions
it is completely 100 unnecessary but it
is 100 completely freaking awesome and
i've been having so much fun and i've
used a lot of different smart watches in
the past from the samsung gear 2 to just
the regular fitbits i've had so many
wearable tech type things on this wrist
i've actually even worn all of them at
the same time so i'm going to go through
a couple of things that i've enjoyed
doing one is the voice to text so i've
been texting my friend ed and i'm gonna
just show you a quick little screenshot
of some of the conversation because when
i use siri i say hey siri
sometimes it
is not so responsive
hey siri
text ed palumbo and tell him that i am
making a video and that i would like for
him to respond immediately because
it is an emergency
it's not really an emergency so don't
worry
it's there
he's probably so annoyed with me i want
i need someone to freaking send me their
heart rate immediately and i don't know
who will send it so right now
i am sending
him my heartbeat
i feel like sending your heart rate to
somebody is a little too intimate unless
it's like you said it's a breeze like
hey dr bree what's my heart rate saying
about me one of my favorite things
though is the force touch so when you
hold down and it'll bring up these
different selections that you can choose
for your watch face so i'm just gonna go
with this nice basic one 32 remaining
i've had this on pretty much all day and
it really didn't what's this
silent mode off is that why i haven't
been getting any notifications
alright force touch let's go back so you
can do all kinds of cool customizations
you can add detail you can take the
detail away
you can swipe over you can change the
colors so you can change each little
section here weather activity timer
stopwatch basically you can
do a lot of cool things let's see what
lamar is up to i'm gonna okay i'm gonna
tap lamar so you can choose different
colors of what color you want to tap
your friend i'm going to tap
so he's going to be receiving these taps
on his phone
oh god now i just started drawing
you will also receive the taps
and a drawing what do you think of me
using it have i been annoying you oh
you've been terrible
you've just been yelling at it and poor
ed like you send ed so many messages she
doesn't really know how to do the night
the proper siri etiquette so you're like
siri tell jenna she's a pig and then
i'll get a text that says she's a pig
i'm like no you're not you're not doing
it right what's handoff what
what does that mean a handoff lets you
start a task on apple watch to continue
on iphone
really
no way my request is ready where's my
phone i don't see that icon i think
you're lying to me you're lying to me
when you hit the camera
app
the camera was open it was closed and
you can now use your watch to take
photos can you push the button
okay hit the three second
you basically can now use your
watch to control
oh my god look at that picture oh wow
that's not good oh it does a 10 burst
which is kind of awesome so yeah 24
hours with the apple watch i've been
enjoying it i think it's pretty awesome
i'm looking forward to having some cool
updates i went to the apple store today
and they actually did have some of the
apple watch chargers so i picked up one
of the one meter and i think the two
meter oh my gosh what
i got i got a notification
okay yay dominic sent me messages is it
in focus yep okay what did he send me
yay he sent me a smiley face what else
did he send me
is that a cheesecake
no
i'm not sure what that was let me send
him one back i'm gonna send him back a
uh
a pink
smiley face
yay
awesome
and it just sends off
anyway after spending a pretty good
amount of time with the aluminum
sportband i'm actually kind of liking it
i really thought that i want the bigger
one i still do definitely want the
bigger one but the steel and the gold
versions are a lot heavier and not to
mention expensive we went to the apple
store today and jenna right here this
girl right here
doesn't really know much about what's
going on in the apple watch world she
points to this rose gold and she's like
wow that's really pretty why didn't you
get it and then we all just looked at
her like i'm sorry
i can't say what i really said i was
like you shut your mouth you don't say
anything bad about apples slap you
upside the head this looks cheap
there is no good reason why anybody in
their right mind should be purchasing a
ten thousand a fifteen thousand dollar
apple watch because you can still switch
out all of the bands you can even take
the sport band and you can get one of
the nicer bands and upgrade that and
it'll look just as nice and it's
expensive and prestigious as those other
ones i couldn't believe it anyway i'm
liking it a lot i'm having a lot of fun
i look forward to traveling a little bit
with it and getting some more use out of
it hey siri
text jenna no he's eric and tell her
no no
perfect all right guys i'll see you
later let me know what else you want to
know about the apple watch and i will
make uh i'll make some more videos for
you guys soon bye bye
i was supposed to be a peace night